>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Betsy Peterson:
Good evening, everyone.
I am Betsy Peterson,
the director
of the American Folk Life Center
here at the Library of Congress.
And behalf of all of
the staff of the center,
I want to welcome you all this
evening to our latest offering
in the Homegrown Concert
series, which is today
or tonight I should say.
We are going to hear four groups
of wonderful musicians
interpreting music
from the collections
in the American Folk
Life Center's archives,
hence the term the
Archives Challenge.
As usual, our performance
tonight is going to be recorded
for later webcast and for
inclusion in our collections.
So with that said, if you do
have a cell phone turned on,
please turn it off at this point
or forever be immortalized
in our archive.
The Homegrown series, just a
little bit of background for all
of you, the Homegrown
series is an opportunity
for the American Folk
Life Center to work
with folk arts coordinators,
ethno-musicologists,
cultural heritage specialists
from throughout the country
to identify some of the very
best artists, musicians,
dancers, storytellers, to sharer
their art and their tradition
with all of you and
with all of us.
So if you want any more
information on the series,
just please go to our website
which is www.LOC.gov/folklife.
A little bit of background now
about the Archive
Challenge itself.
This is our second
Archive Challenge.
We did one about a
year or so ago here
in the Coolidge Auditorium.
And the idea is that
we work with musicians
from around the region to
identify some of the songs
in the archive that they can
interpret and learn, arrange
and perform for all of you.
It's an exciting opportunity
for us and an experiment
that we very much
wish to continue.
So now to tell you a
little bit more about all
of the artists tonight,
I'm going to turn things
over to Steve Winick,
our writer/editor
and folklorist here at
the Folk Life Center.
And actually a musician
in his own right.
So please welcome Steve Winick.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: Good evening.
As Betsy said, I
am Steve Winnick.
I am the writer and editor in
the American Folk Life Center
and I'm a folklorist and I'm
also a singer in the first group
that will be performing tonight.
So I should say that one of
my jobs here at the Center is
to write about the great stuff
that we do and the great ways
that our archive has
been used in the past.
And it came to our
attention over the years
that our archive
has been used by --
[ Inaudible ]
And from Animals to
Feist to Nina Simone,
all kinds of people have
drawn on the archive.
And our thought was, well,
how do we encourage artists
to continue using the archive?
And we came up with the idea
of the Archive Challenge.
And it was really my colleague
Jennifer Cutting whose idea
it was.
And so I am going to
bring out the first group.
I'll tell you a little bit more
about the Archive Challenge
and how it's worked over
the course of the evening.
But right now I'm going
to bring out my colleagues
in Ship's Company Chanteymen.
[ Inaudible ]
Oh. Can we?
All right.
So as I said, we are
Ship's Company Chanteymen,
comprising Myron Peterson,
if you can all wave
when I say your name.
[ Applause ]
Dallas Valley, Michael Bosworth
and myself, Steve Winnick.
And I'm wearing several
hats this evening.
[ Laughter ]
And we are going to be joined
also by Jennifer Cutting
who as I said is the person
whose idea the Archive Challenge
really was.
So we four singers are
part of a larger group
that is called Ship's Company,
and that performs
historical reenactments
and nautical education.
And Ship's Company
reenacts several eras
of American naval history,
especially the war of 1812
which is what these
uniforms are associated with.
Believe it or not, these
hats were worn aboard ships
of war while sailing.
And what we know from historical
records is that sailors went
through several of them a year
because they would blow off
and then they had
to buy a new one.
So I will be sort of narrating
our set and telling you
about the songs that we've
selected from the archive.
Our first song was collected
by James Madison Carpenter
who was a great American
collector of the 1920's
and early 1930's, kind of
an underrepresented era
in folk song collecting.
And he collected both in the
United States and in the UK.
He was American.
He was from Mississippi in fact,
but he was a Harvard scholar
and he was really interested in
sea chanteys and nautical music.
He actually wrote his
dissertation about that.
But his advisor was a man
named George Lyman Kittredge.
And Kittredge had been the
assistant of Francis James Child
who is such a famous ballad
scholar that we have a subgenre
of ballads that we refer
to as Child ballads.
And one of the reasons that
Carpenter was very interested
in this particular song is
that it is a sea chantey
and it's a very well-known
sea chantey.
It's a version of
Blow The Man Down,
which is possibly the
best-known sea chantey there is.
But the lyrics are
totally different
from most other versions
of Blow The Man Down,
except for the refrains.
And the lyrics are in fact
one of these Child ballads
which is a story
about the devil.
Carpenter collected this
combination of Blow The Man Down
and The Devil Ballad
twice in New York City
at Sailor Snug Harbor
in Staten Island
which was a retired
sailors' home.
And once in South
Wales in Cardiff.
And I kind of combined the
verses from these three versions
of this song to get the
one that we're going to do.
So this is called
Blow The Man Down.
And now this is your
interactive part of the evening,
because you're going
to sing with us.
You sing on the refrains.
And many of you will know
this because it is one
of the best-known
songs out there.
So I'm going to sing, "Who lives
in a pineapple under the sea?"
And you're going to sing,
"Way-hey blow the man down."
"Absorbent and porous
and yellow is he."
"Give me some time to
blow the man down."
Except of course those
are not the words
that Carpenter collected.
Carpenter collected these words.
Oh, and I will say there's one
reference in the song which is
to a commercial traveler.
That's just an old word
for a traveling salesman.
And there's a great tradition
of traveling salesmen also
being folklore performers
and folklore collectors.
And so it's appropriate
that the person
in the song meets a
commercial traveler who has
that occupation as well.
So -- [Singing] As I was
a-walking one morning in spring,
way-hey blow the man down.
I found myself next
to an old country inn,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
I sat myself down and
I ordered some gin,
way-hey blow the man down.
A commercial traveler
was the next to come in,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
We talked of the weather
and things of the day,
way-hey blow the man down.
Says he hears a story
I've learned on my way,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
It's of a poor tailor
in London did dwell,
way-hey blow the man down.
The devil he came to
him once out of hell,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
Says he my good friend
now, I've come a long way,
way-hey blow the man down.
Especially this visit
to you for to pay,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
Not you nor your son nor
your daughter I crave,
way-hey blow the man down.
It's your dirty old wife,
she's a drunk old jade,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
So the devil he bundled
her into a sack,
way-hey blow the man down.
And away down to hell
with the wife on his back,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
There were three little imps
there stood outside the gates,
way-hey blow the man down.
She pulled off her slipper
and stove in their pates,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
Three more little devils
were bound down in chains,
way-hey blow the man down.
She took off the other and
bashed in their brains,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
These six little devils
for mercy did bawl,
way-hey blow the man down.
Saying, "Chuck them at
daddy, she'll murder us all,"
give me some time to
blow the man down.
She can't live in heaven,
she's not fit for hell,
way-hey blow the man down.
I'm thinking that London's
a place she could dwell,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
So the devil he bundled
her back in the sack,
way-hey blow the man down.
And back to the tailor
with her on his back,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
She went down to hell
and she came back again,
way-hey blow the man down.
Which proves that the
women are tougher than men,
give me some time to
blow the man down.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: Thank you.
That was James Madison
Carpenter's version
of Blow The Man Down,
mostly from Dennis
O'Connor's in New York City.
And now we're going
to sing another song
that Carpenter collected, and
we're going to be helped here
on the button accordion
by Jennifer Cutting.
And this song is a fishing song.
So Carpenter actually did his
dissertation on nautical songs,
and this one he collected
from a Captain Charles Snellin
in Marblehead, Massachusetts.
One interesting thing about this
song is that we found the tune
in the Carpenter
collection which he sold
to the American Folk Life
Center in the 1970's,
to the Library of Congress.
So it's in the collection,
but we didn't find
words in the collection.
It turns out that the words he
put in his doctoral dissertation
and he said it's the same song
collected from the same person.
So we were able to match
the music to the words.
And the song tells the
story of a fishing voyage
from Massachusetts up
to Atlantic Canada.
And I was familiar with the tune
from a Newfoundland song
called Feller from Fortune.
So it's still in
oral tradition today.
And this song is going to
be sung by Dallas Valley
and Jennifer will
give us the key
and then we'll teach
you the words.
[ Accordion music ]
>> And the chorus
goes, the tune is --
[ Accordion music ]
>> Stephen Winick: And words
are [singing] Shinty sha-long,
shallot, hi, low,
chilly, sha-long, shallot.
[ Music ]
>> [Singing] He was
sitting in the parlor,
thinking over every fan.
In comes Palmer in a hurry to
ship us on board the Frigid Ann.
Shinty sha-long, shallot, hi,
low, chilly, sha-long, shallot.
[ Music ]
We went down to see the skipper
and finding him a
nice young man,
we told him we'd go a-fishing
all on board the Frigid Ann.
Shinty sha-long, shallot, hi,
low, chilly, sha-long, shallot.
[ Music ]
If you want to go a-fishing,
do your duty like a man.
Oil down the shrouds and riggin'
all on board the Frigid Ann.
Shinty sha-long, shallot, hi,
low, chilly, sha-long, shallot.
[ Music ]
Here's the tar now
take the bucket,
rub it in on every strand.
You will stand upon the riggin'
all on board the Frigid Ann.
Shinty sha-long, shallot, hi,
low, chilly, sha-long, shallot.
[ Music ]
We were sitting in the parlor
thinking over every fan,
in comes Palmer in a hurry to
ship us on board the Frigid Ann.
Shinty sha-long, shallot, hi,
low, chilly, sha-long, shallot.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: So our
third song, like the first one,
is a real sea chantey.
And that means that it was
performed by sailors as a way
of coordinating labor
on tall ships.
And sometimes on these
ships there was a person
who was a specialist in singing,
and that person was known
as the chanteyman, and that's
where our group gets the name
from, Ship's Company Chanteymen.
So the chanteymen had to have
a large repertoire of songs
and had to have a good voice
like our friend Myron here
who is also a retired
Navy chief.
Thank you for your service, sir.
And Myron is going
to sing a song
that is called Rueben Ranzo,
which is a well-known
sea chantey
about a tailor who goes to sea.
But we have a version of this
in our archive that was recorded
in 1942 by William
Main Dorflinger
from a retired chanteyman
in New York City,
this one at the Seamen's
Church Institute
down by the South
Street Seaport.
And his name was Patrick Taylor.
And Patrick Taylor
was a real character
and there were actually
newspaper reports about him
at the time because he
was such a crazy guy.
He did all kinds of cool things
like walking from Washington DC
to New York and stuff like
that that got him in the news.
But he also told great
stories about his songs.
And he told a story
about the way
that Reuben Ranzo was written
and we thought we'd
let you hear him tell
that story before
Myron sings the song.
So this is Patrick Taylor
>> It was made up on
[inaudible] when it was known
as Castle Gardens
many years ago.
It's of two poor
fellows sitting together.
One was a hobo and the
other was a tailor.
This man was really a
singer and really a poet.
So when the boarding master's
runner came up, "Hey, feller,"
he says, "Would you
like to go to sea?"
"Why hell no," he
says, "I'm no sailor.
I'm a hobo."
He went to the fellow next
door and he says, "Say, boy,
how would you like
to go to sea?"
"Well," he says, "I'd
love to go to sea, but,"
he says, "I ain't no sailor.
I'm a tailor.
And now I'm busted and broke.
I'm down here on Castle
Gardens living my life out."
And the other fellow looked
at him and the thoughts ran
through his head and
he made this song up.
>> [Singing] It's
poor old Reuben Ranzo,
Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
It's poor old Reuben Ranzo,
Now Ranzo was no tailor,
Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
He was a New York Tailor,
They gave him lashes 30,
Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
Because he was so dirty,
The captain's daughter
Susie, Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
She begged her pa for mercy,
Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
She gave him bread and
water, Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
And a little more
than she ought-ter,
Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
She taught him navigation,
Which brought him to his
station, Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
Now Ranzo, he's a sailor,
Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
And the captain of the
squalor, Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
He's known wherever
the whale-fish blow,
Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
As the hardest bastard on the
gulf, Ranzo, me boys, Ranzo.
>> Stephen Winick: Reuben Ranzo.
Thank you kindly.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And for our final
song we're going
to have Jennifer Cutting
come back up, and she's going
to accompany us on a song
that's called Jolly Roving Tar.
And this is a song that all the
nautical groups around know.
Everybody sings a
version of this song.
But what I didn't know until
I started doing some research,
and particularly until I chatted
with Jeff and Garret Warner
about this, is that
everybody knows this song
because of our collections here
at the Library of Congress.
Because Frank and Anne Warner
collected this song in 1940
from a woman named
Lena Bourne Fish
in East Jaffrey, New Hampshire.
And Mrs. Fish was a farmer's
widow who lived up there
and who had learned this song
from a retired whaling sailor.
And this song, the
Warner's liked it so much
that they played
it for the Lomax's
and the Lomax's published
it in one of their books
which is the way in which it
got out into the folk revival.
So now everybody
sings this song.
But what none of these
people knew, not the Lomax's,
not the Warner's, not Mrs. Fish,
was that this song was
actually an old theater song.
So it was written in the 1850's
in New York City by Ned Harrigan
of all people of
Harrigan and Heart fame.
He was a Broadway composer and
he wrote this song and it was
so popular among sailors
that it went to sea.
And that often happened with
good songs about sailors.
Even though they didn't
originate among sailors,
sailors appropriated them
and took them off to sea.
And we actually have
the original sheet music
of this song on the
Library of Congress website,
but the title is Get
Up Jack, John Sit Down.
And the reason that
we know that everybody
who sings this song got it
from Lena Bourne Fish is
that her version is the
only primary source version
to contain the line Jolly Roving
Tar which is actually the title
of her version of the song.
So this is going to be sung
for us by Mike Bosworth
who among other things is
a retired Navy commander,
but he still hangs
around with us.
So thank you for
your service, sir.
And Jennifer is going to give
us the key and we're going
to teach you the chorus.
[ Music ]
>> [Singing] Come along, come
along, me jolly brave boys,
there's lots of grog in the jar.
We'll plow the briny ocean
with the jolly roving tar.
Ships may come and ships may
go, as long as the sea doth row.
Each sailor lad just like his
dad, he loves the flow and bow.
A trip ashore he does adore with
a girl that's plump and round.
But when your money's all
gone, it's the same old song.
Get up Jack, John sit down.
Come along, come along,
me jolly brave boys,
there's lots of grog in the jar.
We'll plow the briny ocean
with the jolly roving tar.
When Jack gets in,
it's then he'll steer
for some old boarding house.
Now welcome him with
rum and gin,
that'll feed him on pork souse.
He'll lend and spend and not
offend till he lies drunk
on the ground.
When your money's all gone,
it's the same old song,
get up Jack, John sit down.
Come along, come along,
me jolly brave boys,
there's lots of grog in the jar.
We'll plow the briny ocean
with the jolly roving tar.
And then he'll steer aboard
some ship for India or Japan.
In Asia there the ladies
fair all love the sailor man.
He'll go ashore and on a tear
he'll buy some girl a gown.
When your money's all gone,
it's the same old song,
get up Jack, John sit down.
Come along, come along,
me jolly brave boys,
there's lots of grog in the jar.
We'll plow the briny ocean
with the jolly roving tar.
And when Jack's old
and weatherbeat,
too old to rove about,
it's then he'll stop
in some grog shop till
eight bells calls him out.
He'll raise his eyes up to
the skies, saying, "Boys,
we're homeward bound."
When your money's all gone,
it's the same old song,
get up Jack, John sit down.
Come along, come along,
me jolly brave boys,
there's lots of grog in the jar.
We'll plow the briny ocean
with the jolly roving tar.
Come along, come along,
me jolly brave boys,
there's lots of grog in the jar.
We'll plow the briny ocean
with the jolly roving tar.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick:
Jolly Roving Tar.
We have been The Ship's
Company Chanteymen.
Once again, Mike Bosworth,
Myron Peterson, Dallas Valley
and our good friend and AFC
colleague Jennifer Cutting.
[ Applause ]
Now they all get to leave, but
I have to stay because I've got
to tell you about the
next person who's coming
out onto our stage.
And that will be Jaimeo Brown.
And Jaimeo had been a
drummer since the age of 16
and has played with some
of the top names in music.
Stevie Wonder, Carlos Santana.
And he has become inspired by
some of our field recordings
in the Library of Congress.
Especially originally the Gees
Bend recordings from Alabama.
And he put those together
and sort of sampled them
for a project of his
called Transcendence.
And he's just one in
a long line of artists
who have sampled AFC material
starting back in the '90's
with Moby, did a lot of
sampling of our work.
And most recently Beyonce used
some of our work as samples.
So it's another way
in which people engage
with our recordings.
And Jaimeo came to the
reading room a couple years ago
and I got the opportunity
to meet him and we hung out
and we showed him
some work songs.
And he's adapted some of
those for his project today.
So this is the great
Jaimeo Brown.
Do you want to speak
before you play?
>> Jaimeo Brown: All right.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Wow, it's an honor,
honor really being here.
As he mentioned, I've been
interested in the archives
for probably around
four or five years now.
And of course when
I came I didn't know
that I would actually
be performing here.
So it's a great circle
kind of for myself.
What you're about to hear,
you're about to hear
something that's probably going
to be a little bit different
than something you
may have heard before.
The music that you're going
to hear a sample tonight
specifically comes
from a collection of Lomax
recordings called kind
of The Parchman Farms
Collection,
which is actually a
prison in Alabama.
And some of the work
songs that were sung
in the prisons were really
songs that retained some
of the very first
concepts and ideas
of the very first African
American experience
in the country.
So the music is very important
and significant because out
of the work songs, out of
the earliest spirituals,
this is really the roots of
so much of what we consider
to be American music
and American pop music.
If we're talking about jazz
or talking about the blues,
or we're talking about rock
or we're talking about funk
or we're talking about a lot
of forms of electronic music,
all of these different modern
forms have roots that go back
to these really early,
early sounds
and these early spirituals
and work songs.
So from these recordings I took
some of the ideas of things
that I feel came from these.
So you're going to hear rhythms
that all have roots
in these recordings.
And it's kind of my
interpretation as a drummer here
as well as you can
see of this material.
So thank you guys so
much for being here,
and have a wonderful night.
I'm honored to be here with
such diverse artists tonight,
scanning all around the world
with the sounds that
you're hearing.
[ Singing ]
[ Music ]
[ Music and singing ]
[ Birds chirping ]
[ Bass rumbling ]
[ Singing ]
[ Birds chirping ]
[ Bass rumbling ]
[ Drumming ]
[ Singing ]
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Jaimeo Brown: Thank you.
Thank you.
Yes, once again, you're
hearing really the roots.
Some of those voices and
some of those songs and some
of those prison songs,
you're hearing a lot of roots
of where the blues actually
came from within those voices.
So this is very important to
me just because it really is
like when you look at a tree,
a tree that's very old has
so many long branches
on it, you know.
But you don't often
see the roots
of how deep those roots actually
go, deep underneath the ground.
And that really is a big
purpose of this music,
to understand really the
deepest roots of this music.
It's an honor being here.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you Library of Congress.
Have a great night.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: Wow.
Thank you to Jaimeo Brown.
Yeah, and what Jaimeo is
saying is so important.
This really is the
roots of American music
and pretty much all genres
of American popular
music have their roots
in traditional musics that
you can find in our archive.
And I promised I'd tell you a
little bit more about the origin
of the Archive Challenge
later in the evening,
and that's what I'm
going to do now.
So the Archive Challenge, as
I said, it came about because
for all these years
we've been observing all
of the great musicians who have
found their way to the archive.
But often that finding
was fortuitous.
They found their way
here because of a book
that was published that
had a transcription
or someone happened to put
out some field recordings
on a commercial release
and they heard those.
The library did a
little of that too.
We released some of them
on LP's back in those days.
But we were trying
to think of ways
that we could encourage
this more directly.
And as I mentioned, my colleague
Jennifer Cutting was the person
who kind of had this idea,
because Jennifer and I used
to attend the Folk Alliance
Conference every year.
This is sort of an industry
conference for folk music,
where a lot of groups get
together in order to sort
of ply their wares essentially
to promoters and presenters.
And so we thought this
would be a great place
to actually get the
archive challenge going.
So Jennifer had this idea
of promoting these two bands
at the beginning, a few months
before the meeting was going
to start, get them to learn
stuff from the archive.
And they work with
reference librarians
at the American Folk
Life Center.
And we help them find material
that they would like to adapt
and adapt that material into
something that they can perform.
And then at the Folk Alliance
itself, there is a showcase
and this allows these
musicians to put those in front
of presenters and other people
who might want to put them on.
And so that worked really
well for several years.
But last year we had the
idea, "Hey, why not bring this
to Washington as well, bring
this right here to the stage
of the Library of Congress?"
And so we engaged
in that process.
We did essentially
the same thing,
except it's mostly local artists
or regional, we would say,
people from around here.
And we got three
or four artists.
Actually last year we
got five artists to come
and do the archive challenge,
and that was a noontime show
like many of our programs in
the Homegrown Concert series.
This year we decided to
move it to evening time,
and we've got these
four artists.
So that was sort
of the trajectory.
And again, it's all
about getting this music
into the hands of artists, not
just listeners, not just people
who will appreciate it,
but people who will
do something with it.
And so that's what we've
had so far and we're going
to continue in that vein.
Now, the American Folk Life
Center was founded in 1976
and we were founded by
Congressional legislation.
And that legislation
gives us a mandate,
and one of the first things
that it says about the reason
for creating an American
Folk Life Center is
that the diversity inherent
in American folk life
is very important
to the American people, and
that this diversity should
be maintained.
And so we're actually
quite proud and happy
to have diversity at
the heart of what we do
and as the reason
for what we do.
And that's one of the
reasons why the showcase
that you're going to
see tonight has a lot
of diverse artists in it.
And the next act that we're
going to see is in itself --
there's diversity in the group
because it's a Palestinian
and Persian music
fusion together.
So it's Arabic and Persian.
And it's Huda and Kamyar.
And they are the duo of Huda
Asfour and Kamyar Arsani.
Huda comes from a musical family
and she had formal training
in music in Tunis, in Gaza,
in Ramala and in Cairo.
She's a founder of Jahar Band
which is a musical experiment
which molded together Arabic,
folk and classical Arabic music
into reinterpretations
that would be relatable
for younger Palestinians.
And she's the recipient of
several prestigious grants
and awards for her work.
Kamyar is a
multi-instrumentalist, a singer
and a songwriter, and he was
born and raised in Tehran, Iran.
Kamyar has spent over
20 years performing
and researching the
Daf and its roots,
the main instrument
he'll be playing tonight.
And he also plays
several other instruments.
And he has taught himself
how to play melodica ukulele
and all kinds of things, but his
central instrument is the Daf.
And his songs and performances
are inspired by the people
of Iran and their history
of struggle and protest.
So next we are going to
present Huda and Kamyar.
[ Applause ]
>> Huda Asfour: And really when
we looked into the material
that we found in the
archives, there were a lot
of technical problems in terms
of how old the recordings were,
how much noise there
was in there.
Most of these were collected
as part of field recordings,
parts of dissertations
and scholarly work.
And many of them were sort of
on the way to other places.
So passing by this fusion.
So we chose three different
pieces from different places.
The first was inspired by a
collection of Coptic hymns.
The collection name
is the Divine Liturgy
of St. Basel with its hymns.
And these are recordings
that were produced
between '64 and '67.
So we will start with an
improvisation inspired
by these Coptic hymns.
And the reason I found
those fascinating is
that sometimes I think
in the subconscious --
the social settings that I
grew up in, I get surprised
when I hear Christian hymns that
sound so native to the region
with a lot of influence
from what could have been had
I not known also recitation
of Koran.
So for me, it's really beautiful
to see how the local
music plays its role
in defining the identity
of religious recitations.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Kamyar Arsani: All
right, this next one,
this was a tough one too.
We found it and we fixed the
recording of [foreign name].
He was a person from
the Loreson area of Iran
that the song is picked from.
This song was written
during the Iran/Iraq War
and there's a story of a son
of the family getting on a bike
and wanting to tell his mother
that he's going to the war
and he's going to the
front of the lines.
And it is time for war.
So the chorus of this
song says, "Mother,
Mother, it's time for war.
And I hope I have all
my bullets on me."
And I think the part
that was amazing
to us was the description,
the imagery of it
and how it wasn't a sad moment.
It wasn't that I'm
going to war to die.
It was more of a, "I am
giving my life for my people."
So the song wasn't
supposed to be a sad song.
It actually became a war
hymn during the Iran/Iraq War
and a lot of soldiers
were singing it
to keep their spirit up.
It's called [foreign name].
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
>> Kamyar Arsani: Thank you.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Winick: The
beautiful, beautiful music
of Huda and Kamyar, Kamyar
and Huda, our great duo
of Persian and Arabic music.
Thank you guys so
much, and another round
of applause for Huda and Kamyar.
[ Applause ]
So in a few minutes we're going
to year from our next group,
Elena and Los Fulanos.
But before we do, I'm going
to tell you a little bit
about upcoming programs, because
the programming team here
at the American Folk Life
Center never stops working.
We have a symposium coming
up on Monday about the work
of cultural institutions
including the Center
for Traditional Music
and Dance in New York,
Apple Shop in Kentucky, and Drum
and Spear Bookstore
here in Washington DC.
And there will be
representatives
of all those organizations
here to talk about the work
that their institutions
have done for,
in some cases, 50 years.
We are having a concert
on the 26th,
that is this coming Wednesday.
The National Heritage
Fellowship winner Eddie Bond
who is a fiddler,
and he'll be playing
with the New Ballard's
Branch Bog Trotters
which is a great old-time band.
And they'll be here in this
room from noon to 1:00.
I'll post all of this, which you
can see our blog is called Folk
Life Today.
And so Elena was one of the
participants in that program.
And then I got to see her last
year at Folk Alliance and then
when we were thinking of
people for this program,
we started to hear
rumblings from our friends
who were promoters in the
area that you really have
to have Elena and Los
Fulanos here on the stage.
And we thought, "Hey,
that's a great idea.
We already love her, so
let's get her over here."
And that's what we did.
So we invited Elena and
Los Fulanos to be here
for the Archive Challenge.
So this is a bilingual folk
rock band based right here
in Washington DC.
They've been performing
since 2011
and they've been creating
some great music since then.
They have won Wammy Awards
from the Washington Area Music
Association, and great accolades
from the Washington Post.
So a big warm welcome for
Elena and Los Fulanos.
[ Applause ]
>> Elena: Thank you.
It's such a pleasure
to be here tonight.
And we had this awesome
opportunity
and we were really excited to
dig into the archives here.
If you have heard
of Los Fulanos,
we mostly do original music,
but we do like to think
that we do a little bit
of ethno-musicology.
And so it was a really cool
thing to go into the archives,
and one of the most exciting
things we found was we found
this recording from
1943 -- no, '34.
And it was one of the
early Lomax recordings.
And it was in Spanish and it
was in one of the first kind
of discs that we found.
And no one apparently
had really written
down the lyrics or
translated it.
On the recording, I think
it's Lomax that sang.
It's called Conscripted Soldier.
It was recorded in
Texas and it is about --
so the first line and the
only thing that was written
on the little notecard that
we found was, [Spanish phrase]
which means President
Wilson conscripted me.
So I was like, "I've got
to look into this song.
This has got to be
something interesting,
something political."
And something written
about an American president
but in Spanish.
And so we listened to the
song, wrote out all the lyrics
and it's about draft dodgers
in Texas that would go instead
of being drafted into the First
World War, they decided to go
to Mexico which is a
very reasonable thing,
considering that Mexican
Americans and Texans
in the US were treated
as second-class citizens.
So this is kind of a story of --
still a lot of Mexican Americans
and Mexicans, Texanos, went
to war and did fight and die.
But many of them also escaped.
And those that did go
unfortunately had to come back
to a country that didn't
see them as full citizens.
So we took this song and the
new kind of built it out.
When we heard it,
it was just one guy
with a guitar playing
probably in a living room.
So we built it up a little bit
and made it more of a song,
more of a complete song.
So we're going to
see how this goes.
Ready? Do you remember?
Okay.
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
>> Elena: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
This next song -- actually
we included a key change
for the music people out there.
We included a key
change in that song
because really funnily enough,
in the middle of his recording,
Jose Villa I think is his
name, the original recording,
he just kind of changes key kind
of in the middle of a phrase.
We were like, "Oh, that's
kind of an interesting thing."
So we included it.
This next selection
that we picked is
from an awesome group called
Quetzal which is a group
that is based out of LA.
And they did actually show here
at the Library of
Congress in 2011.
And this is a selection
from that.
I kind of looked through it.
I really wanted to do
a song from this group
because they do justice-oriented
music that's informed
by Son jarocho, which
is a traditional music
from Baracus, Mexico.
And Danny over here is from
[Mexican name] and he was raised
in Mariachi and Son
jarocho traditions.
Today he's going to be doing El
Sapatial on -- what's it called?
Tarima, yeah.
Stage name.
Tarima. And he also informed us
that the dance that he's going
to be doing today isn't
typically associated
with the men's side
of the dance.
This is a women's
dance, but we're okay
with breaking gender stereotypes
here at Elena and Los Fulanos.
[ Applause ]
But one of the things that I
really loved about this song,
it's really a fun song to play.
But also the lyrics
are really awesome.
It's about a mocking
bird, a sinsonte.
And one of the lines that really
grabs me about this song is
that it says, [Spanish
phrase], dignity is the revenge.
But it's not like revenge.
It's kind of like dignity is
kind of like your comeback.
You know, and I think a lot
of oppressed communities,
especially I feel like
it's relevant now,
is just like carrying your
head high and doing your best
and being dignified
is the best way
to show your own
way to fight back.
So that's what I really
liked about this song,
and it's also pretty awesome,
so let's see how it goes.
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
[ Applause ]
>> Elena: Manny Cervantes
on the violin.
[ Applause ]
Kevin de Sousa on bass.
Andrew Northrup on the cajon and
various percussion instruments.
Sweet. So when we were asked
to do this, actually I came
to a show here that was
very formative for me.
Actually, after we did
the songwriting workshop,
which apparently they're
having another one,
so you should look that up.
It was a really cool experience.
But after we had the Corido
workshop here at the Library
of Congress, I actually came
to the Canciones de Mexico
concert that evening.
And it was really awesome.
The songwriting workshop
was taught be the lead
of Canciones de Mexico.
And one of the songs that they
did was a bilingual version
of This Land is Your Land which
has been pretty important for me
because there's been so
much political activism.
I've been asked to play at a
lot of protests and rallies.
And in particular, I started
using This Land is Your Land
as a song that could really
bring a lot of people together.
Everybody knows how the song
goes, everybody can sing along.
But not everybody knows the
justice elements that went
into the original writing
of This Land is Your Land.
Woody Guthrie actually wrote it.
He was originally from
Oklahoma, but he moved
to California during the
Dust Bowl, and he faced a lot
of discrimination for
being from Oklahoma.
And he wrote This Land is Your
Land kind of in response to some
of the nationalistic
elements that were coming out.
Some of the kind of same things
that we see now that are coming
out in xenophobia and
that kind of stuff.
So we're going to do a
bilingual version of that.
And before we start it,
I want to teach you
the part in Spanish.
It's a little hard, but
might as well give it a try.
If you guys sing what you
can, are you cool with that?
Are we good?
We're going to do
a little performing
and build participation.
Cool. So it goes like this.
Esta tierra es tu tierra.
Repeat with me.
>> Esta tierra es tu tierra.
>> Elena: Esta tierra es mia.
>> Esta tierra es mia.
>> Elena: Desde horizonte.
>> Desde horizonte.
>> Elena: Yeah, the horizon.
Asta la otro rilla.
>> Asta la otro rilla.
>> Elena: So la otro rilla
is to the other edge.
Desde las montanas.
>> Desde las montanas.
>> Elena: To the mountiains.
Costas rillos e vallas.
>> Costas rillos e vallas.
>> Elena: That one's
the hard part.
La tierras parte e parame.
>> Elena: Yeah, we have some
Spanish speakers in here.
So yeah, we're going to do this.
We hope you sing along, sing
along to anything that you'd
like or that you know.
And the other thing I wanted
to say about this is one
of my favorite verses of this
that doesn't always get sung is,
there's a verse about
getting to a wall.
I actually don't
know it in English.
"But when I got to a wall,
there was a sign there
that said no trespassing,
and on the other side
it didn't say nothing."
Which Canciones de Mexico retook
and made it about the border,
and we'll sing that verse today.
So cool. Listos.
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
In English now.
This land is your land,
this land is my land.
From California to
the New York Islands.
From the redwood forests
to the Gulf Stream waters.
This land was made
for you and me.
Eso.
[ Music ]
[ Singing ]
In English now.
This land is your land,
this land is my land.
From California, to
the New York Islands.
From the redwood forests
to the Gulf Stream waters.
This land was made
for you and me.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Stephen Winick: Another
big thank you to Elena
and Los Fulanos, and to
the other great artists
that we've presented tonight,
Huda and Kamyar, Jaimeo Brown
and the Ship's Company
Chanteymen and Jennifer Cutting.
I want to also thank -- there's
a whole rack of people to thank
for this event, including Wiz,
Ed and Chris on the sound,
John Gold our recording
engineer, Roger for helping
with the tech of the video.
Our multimedia team,
Michelle Glymph doing lights.
And then on the American Folk
Life Center staff, Thea Austen,
Jennifer Cutting, John Fen,
Michelle Stefano, Maya Lerman,
Nancy Gross and of course
Betsy Peterson our director
who introduce the show.
We want to thank
you all for coming.
Take a look around.
There are some of the artists
lurking around with CD's
that you could buy from them.
And we want to ask you to come
on back for all those events
that I described that
we're having next week.
So thank you so much for coming.
This has been another great
archive challenge here
at the American Folk Life Center
at the Library of Congress.
And thanks to you for coming
out and seeing the show.
Good night, everyone.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.